[Musique]
bonjour galonnés bonjourbonjour
martinique la première et bonjour aussi
aux auditeurs de matinée que la première
mais aussi à aux auditeurs d'hugo nord
notamment le lorrain alors justement au
lourd 1 vous étiez déjà candidat pour
des élections municipales en 2008 en
2014 aussi pour les élections
municipales et communautaires et vous
menez cette année la liste union pour un
lorrain autrement donc si on compte bien
galonnés c'est votre troisième tentative
vous ne vous en lasser pas il ne faut
jamais se lasser et lorsqu'on a à faire
passer des idées
lorsqu'on a envie de permettre à halle
en tout cas d'être heureux et c'est à ce
que je me suis attelé depuis déjà
longtemps et de dire que investir dans
l'humain c'est un bon investissement
alors fort de tout cela et dans le
milieu associatif ou me suis permis de
mettre en place des idées innovantes et
la sab le mans je suis venu pour pouvoir
les expérimentés c'est un véritable
laboratoire que nous avons mis en place
dans le nord de la martinique notamment
le système d'échangé local que devrait
poursuivre sa route vers une monnaie
sociale complémentaire et bien
évidemment les épiceries solidaires à
l'échelon communal que j'envisage de
mettre un système qui taxent
participatif et je crois à travers tout
cela je suis un peu plus de plain pied
dans le développement durable
alors on va on va revenir alors
j'aimerais possible et ce n'est pas une
ion points l'om en ce moment mais c'est
young et pilote pour laurens ah ok le
groupe peut-être ces unions le groupe
union pour nous montrer où le groupe
n'est plus à ça ne porte plus son nom ne
s'importe plus en changer le nom avant
changement
de la ligue 2 l'as laissé tout alors
préciser de nouveau précisé nous alors à
lancer l'yonne et puis leur poule o 1
c'est à la fois le nom du groupe est de
la liste d'un du groupe et de la liste
très bien alors on va revenir sur ce que
vous voulez a mené de votre expérience
associative en quelque sorte vous venez
différentes visions ce que comment
voulez l'appliquer à éventuellement à un
mandat de maire mais gannoun est tout de
même alors vous ne vous nous avez dit
pourquoi vous ne vous en lasser pas de
vous présenter aux élections municipales
mais qu'est ce qui vous motive encore
alors qu'en 2014
vous aviez recueilli 30% des suffrages 1
autrement dit justin pamphile le maire
sortant là avaient été ainsi élu dès le
premier tour
ça ne vous décourage pas ça ce résultat
d'il ya six ans je ne me décourage pas
parce que c'était les projets innovants
compote
il faut inlassablement arrivé à
permettre aux gens de se conscientiser
et de dire que le monde a changé
les finances publiques sont très très
difficile j'entends beaucoup de deux
personnes de mer qui parle effectivement
que des projets ne sont pas réalisés et
qu' il faut chercher les finances et
personnellement je crois qu'il ya une
autre voie
entreprendre autrement est ce que j'ai
expérimenté qui en quelque sorte est
pour moi un laboratoire d'expériences et
jeu là je sais steam peuvent
certainement pour cela il faut au niveau
allait rapidement là dessus parce que
après ce sera très difficile de ne pas
pouvoir faire ce que nous avons su le
faire et de dire qu'on peut mieux faire
je reviens à 2014 parce que là cette
année ça change en 2014
vous n'étiez que deux candidats cette
année vous êtes 3 est ce que c'est de
nature à vous donner un peu d'espoir ou
est-ce que vous estimez que le combat la
lutte sera encore plus difficile
finalement rapidement
j'aime les spams et mes réflexions sur
ce à chaque fait sa route
moi mon objectif c'est de dire est ce
qu'on peut faire mieux devant la
situation actuelle que nous avons est il
possible d'entreprendre autrement
alors qu'est ce que vous pourriez quelle
est la proposition phare de
votre campagne votre il y aura beaucoup
de proposer tout ce qui va dans dans
l'humain tout ce que que nous pouvons
mettre comme humain au coeur de nos
décisions par exemple lorsque nous
faisons l'épicerie solidaire et que j'ai
convocation de l'étendre sur le t3 pense
que c'était directement centré sur le
bourg du lorrain cette misère est
partout
j'ai installé beaucoup de puisque
solidaire à la martinique et que en ce
qui me concerne cela doit donc je reçois
forme ce que vous avez fait attendez qui
a donné ce que vous avez fait avec
justement ces épiceries solidaires ce
maillage ce réseautage en quelque sorte
vous dites que vous pouvez l'appliquer à
l'échelon municipal aux lorrains voir à
l'échelon communautaire pour les autres
communes du nord enfin voila c'est un
peu ça c'est dans ces expériences et 7
700 semble mais non seulement adaptés
notamment les épiceries solidaires dans
différents quartiers notamment les
principaux quartiers du lourd 1 2 un
premier temps notamment le quartier mont
un capot et le quartier le quart des
carabins
mais le faire aller dans le sens de la
participation de l'équipe à ce héros
donner vie si vous voulez aux petits
commerces aux petites entreprises qui
sont là que sont fermées dans le nord et
l'est des ya mieux à faire et comment
les encourager à mettre en place des des
boutiques de proximité
merci merci guy annonay d'avoir
participé à ce 5 à 10 pc municipal à la
réalisation cédric berkeley